hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar
innovations in vaccine research and
development
i am jennifer woods of labyrinth and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by
thermo fisher scientific to learn more
visit thermofisher.com we encourage you
to participate today by submitting any
questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speakers
alexandra
sasha vlasov senior manager r
d at thermo fisher scientific laura
chapman
staff scientist at thermo fisher
scientific
kettle peterson manager and staff
scientist at thermo fisher scientific
and matt mckenna senior field
application scientist at thermo fisher
scientific
sasha you may now begin your
presentation
thank you uh i will
go through quick introduction then hand
it over to uh laura ketchum matt for the
main body of presentation uh many of you
know that
the story of vaccine development goes
back to
1796 and dr jenner and his amazing
work and bright discoveries in smallpox
and
since then it's been 220 years of
scientifical medical innovation
adventures there are many stories to
tell and looking back for me it's just
mind-blowing how much happened in such a
relatively short
time frame in particular the last few
decades
it was not only about efficient
development of vaccines for
all key bacterial and viral infections
but also about a wide
extent of implementation worldwide so
now we completely eliminated some of the
infectious diseases of plague humanity
for many years
but also as many of them are under
control and we have
very efficient machinery worldwide to
develop new vaccines in very short
time frame speaking about types of
vaccines now there are different
approach
how uh specialists prepare them
the first one is in activating vaccines
when a pathogen is
inactivated by heat chemical substances
or radiation
and then it's safe to administer upon
intramuscular injection and
it enables very efficient vaccination
with the short
investment in the activation vaccine
production
next one is life attenuative vaccines
followed by subunit
recombinant polycystic right and
conjugate vaccines neurotoxoid vaccines
pretty recent development
i am personally very passionate and
excited about nucleic acid vaccines
which is the
latest development many of you heard
about success stories from pfizer and
moderna
that were among the very first vaccines
launched for
covet infection and they were developed
uh just within
about one year of of research we can't
really say that they were developed from
scratch
mrna therapeutics and vaccines were
already actively explored by scientists
over the last five or ten years
uh they were very good modifications
already known uh to stabilize
mrna minimize immune response they were
already very good uh
delivery vehicles explored based on
ketone eclipses and nanoparticles
but the main effort was aimed at
mrna therapeutic development and these
were efforts by modern and several other
key companies
so vaccines were de-emphasized and
basically at the time of pandemic
it was uh amazing to see that everything
happened from the very beginning
to finalizing uh basically vaccine
development to launch it i commercialize
it and
injecting millions of people worldwide
in just one year
vaccines are developed in a very
sophisticated manner so it's lengthy
step-by-step process uh the current
slide alleges some of the key steps
uh first target discovery need to very
efficiently isolate and characterize
your pathogen of interest
then follows antigen identification
selection
uh production of antigen then this
process and analytical development
clinical studies which are super
important that all starts with safety
then the sufficiency studies
and the long-term effect exploration and
finally commercial production
and the mass distribution worldwide
which is a separate
big challenge so you can imagine so that
not only tens of millions of those
vaccines should be produced every week
or every month but they should be
delivered to every corner of the world
and they're safely administered to human
subjects
a separate challenge in case of
covariate vaccine when double injection
is required so it's logistical nightmare
and it's just really amazing for me to
see how efficiently it was all done at
the time of covet pandemic
vaccine development is a long and
sophisticated process that
requires many specialized tools and
carefully optimized
workflows a thermofish scientific quad
range of years developed all reagents
kits instruments solutions and build
expertise
to help with vaccine development from
the very early stages through
launch and mass production these
solutions range for instance in case of
embryonics in development from
ntps and transcription enzymes to
delivery formulations to large scale
production processes
to even freezers uh allowing to store
marina vaccines at ultra low
temperatures we have all of this in our
portfolios
there are too many products to cover in
today's presentations we'll be just
highlighting the the critical ones the
selective ones
lauren cattle will be presenting the key
products from the sample prep portfolio
kits and reagents for purification of
plasmid dna
genomic dna rna and some other products
which are extremely useful for
development of vaccines
using all approaches that i mentioned on
previous slide but in particular
nucleic acid based vaccines matt will be
presenting on xp expression system as a
very important tool for vaccine
development
this is introduced on the current slide
protein expression is the method of
producing
proteins using cell lines we develop
fantastic systems that allow to obtain
large amounts of protein to study its
functional structure or use in vaccine
development purposes
especially for production of recombinant
vaccines so this is a very exciting
application
as you all know the last probably year
and a half
the entire scientific and medical
community worldwide so all academic
organizations biotech pharma
medical research centers they will
solely focus on coronavirus
research and everyone abandoned all
other topics
and it was really impressive to see how
rapidly coronavirus was characterized
from uh basic research standpoint so
basically what is the composition of
this virus
how exactly tender cells how it
multiplies inside
how it's spreading throughout the body
how it's transferred from one
human subject to another and at the same
time it was
very interesting to see the very rapid
and very efficient
uh basically solution for
eradication of this problem worldwide
there are many different
organizations that attracted from
different angles uh
many examples of brilliant collaboration
and amazing solutions launched in
extremely short time frame
speaking about new vaccine development
the process usually takes
five years in some cases for truly new
vaccines it could be
longer it's step by step process there
are good reasons why exactly this
process evolved and
whether a certain checkpoint certain
areas
of research they take certain number of
time but the desperate time of pandemics
of course all these rules were broken
and the new
scheme emerged that allowed to
dramatically uh
accelerate the vaccine development
process from five plus years to just one
year or less
we're really excited about this latest
breakthroughs in
vaccine development it was very
impressive to witness how
covet molecular diagnostics emerge first
in the early days pandemic and we're a
big part of this
development and then vaccines and
therapies candidates which are the
ultimate solution obviously
emerged within just one year since the
beginning of coronavirus outbreak
we closely worked all this time with
pfizer
moderna and other companies that already
launch vaccines
as well as many other organizations
worldwide that are at the early phase of
discovery and vaccine development
uh our goal overall is to develop
innovative negative solutions and keep
supporting everyone with their
research and manufacturing needs when it
comes to molecular diagnostic vaccine
development
and therapies it's truly exciting time
for us really impressive to see what
happened in the last year
and i'm now passing the presentation
over to laura chapman
okay thank you sasha
so as sasha mentioned i'm going to be
talking about some of the
solutions that we offer from thermo
fisher for sample prep
and sample prep we refer to as the
extraction of rna or dna from a sample
type or even proteins i'm going to be
focusing on rna and dna extraction
so just to kind of give a high level
overview
of what we refer to as sample prep in a
nutshell
it's any kind of sample that you may be
working with that you would like to
extract the rna or dna out of and
there's a variety of different methods
that you can use
to extract the rna and dna um
and then you would choose those
different methods depending on
the your outcome that you want whether
it be your downstream application or
the analyte that you're interested in so
i want to talk a little bit more in
detail about some of these methods
in general there are three basic types
of methods to
prepare your rna or dna for analysis
the first one is the gold standard of
phenol based extraction or trivol
that we offer from thermo fissure this
is by far
like the highest purity and the gold
standard for extracting rna and dna
it will work with pretty much any sample
type and you're guaranteed to get high
quality
nucleic acid from it the challenge comes
in that it's
low throughput it's very hands-on it's
not very
adaptable for using it for multiple
samples
and then the other problem is that it is
highly toxic reagents that are
that are being used in the process but
you get high quality reagents
or high quality nucleic acid
the other option that you can use for
purifying your rna or dna is a solid
phase extraction
something using like our pure link
column based kits or our magmax bead
based kits
with these both of the uh both of them
work with a similar concept and the fact
that the rna or dna is bound to the
solid phase
in the column example it would be the
the membranes that are at the bottom of
the column and then with the bead based
extraction kits it's bound to the beads
you would wash in a loop
and then be able to use it in your
downstream application the benefit of
this
is that it's much more high throughput
than trisol um it's
can be automated for the bead-based ones
you can use our kingfisher
to be able to automate that make it a
little bit easier to
process up to 96 samples at a time
and then lastly is just preparing a
crude lysate that can go directly into
qrt pcr
for your downstream gene expression
analysis an example of this
is ourselves the ct product line and so
the benefit of this is that it's very
high throughput
you only need to life and then add a
stop solution so the sample prep takes
less than 10 minutes for a 96 well plate
but you don't have the purity there so
if you need to do other downstream
applications such as sequencing this may
not be the best fit
but it's perfect for qr2pcr analysis
one of our kits that i wanted to
highlight just because of
um its growing um
use in the in the world of diagnostic or
not necessarily diagnostic but for
biomarker detection so
with this kit it's our magmax cell free
total nucleic acid kit the benefit of
this kit is that it extracts
cell free dna that's free floating
within a liquid biopsy
a liquid biopsy is a emerging sample
type
and an emerging diagnostic tool because
it's much easier to obtain than a
traditional biopsy
so you could take a portion of blood or
urine or sputum or saliva or some other
liquid from from a person and be able to
look for biomarkers that could help
look for diseases so this kit that we
offer
works really well and the example shown
in the data here is looking at a
bioanalyzer trace of cell free nucleic
acid
so cell free dna and rna is
very small um the little tiny blip
that you can see on the trace on the day
ones at the um
on the baseline that is your cell free
dna so it's about 140 base pairs on
average
and so it's quite small and it's very
minimal for the
amount of dna and rna that's uh that's
cell free within your samples
and then here we're comparing with two
different collection tubes the strec
tubes which are the benefit of that is
that it is specifically designed for
cell free dna and so it prevents you
from
extracting nucle genomic dna which can
be a contaminant
whenever you're looking for cell free
dna and so you can see in day 14 there's
a bigger hump down at the end
that's the genomic dna but with the
structures that's much smaller than with
just the k2 edta
tubes so if you are looking for
cell-free dna tools the struct tubes
work really well
they work well with our magmax cell free
dna kit
and then the other benefit of the kit is
that it also
works better with not getting the
genomic dna
so some of the competitor kits you get a
little bit more genomic dna which can be
difficult
whenever you're doing your sequencing
downstream
it can prevent you from getting the read
depth that you would want for your
cell free dna
another tool that i wanted to highlight
is the cells to ct kits
so the benefit of these as i mentioned
with the extraction protocol
is that it's actually not an extraction
it's just a lysis
based kit so that you can just slice
your sample and go directly into your
qpcr
the benefit of this is that it's really
beneficial for
high throughput screening so if you are
maybe doing transactions of plasmids and
you want to see
the expression levels make sure that the
rda is being expressed
you could quickly do a screening using
the cells the ct kit
that will allow you to like the cells
and then go directly into qpcr
and look for your target gene of
interest without having to isolate the
rna
and go through the process of purifying
your rna or dna
so as i mentioned it's only a seven
minute sample prep
it does you just add the lysis buffer
let it sit for
five minutes then add your stop buffer
let it sit for two minutes and then it
can go directly into your
rt qpcr and we have options for one step
and two steps
so if you're doing a screening
especially a gene expression screening
this would be really great um and for
example if it was like the
the plasmids then you would be able to
look for that expression to make sure
it's expressing what you want it to
before going on to your next level
the next kit i would like to highlight
is our microbial
workflows so we have three different
kits that are offered
to look for microbial and pathogens
so we have the magma spiral pathogen and
then the next version is the magmato
pathogen ultra
and then the magmax microbiome ultra so
the vital pathogen kit is our core kit
it's a really easy to use
only takes about 20 25 minutes on the
kingfisher flex to be able to isolate
viral
nucleic acids from your samples this was
widely used
during the pandemic to be able to
isolate the rna from dtm samples that
were collected from nasal swabs
and then more recently with saliva
samples that were collected it also
works with those
and so it's been a great tool during the
pandemic to be able to detect
and notify people that they have that
they have the
sars co2 virus the next version is the
ultra
and the difference there is that it has
an extra tube of enzyme mix
that helps life the more difficult to
life
like gram-positive bacteria fungi those
kind of things that are more challenging
to life
it has an extra set of enzymes to help
you lyses more efficiently
and then lastly is the microbiome ultra
kit so this
is um still uses the core reagents for
the lysosome wash
but this one is specifically used for
like stool samples or wastewater samples
so that you can
look at the different pathogens and
microbes that are within
a person's microbiome
the next set of kits i wanted to speak
to is our plasma dna applications and so
these are
especially beneficial to vaccine
development
especially for the the mrna vaccines
so generally the um you would start with
your plasmid and do an ivt reaction to
get your
your mrna and then that was is what is
used in
the vaccines and so you would need to
start with high quality
plasma dna and so there are three basic
types of
plasma dna extraction kits for different
uses
the first one is a molecular grade one
so this is where you just want to
check the sequence of it you want to do
molecular applications
you don't need to do transactions or um
or any kind of in vitro
work the next is transfection grade
hence the name it's due
it's mostly used for transfection so
it's a little bit
better purity um so that it doesn't have
any downs
it doesn't have side effects to your
cells or cause cytotoxicity whenever you
transfect so it's a cleaner prep
um and it provides you really high
quality dna to use in your transfections
and then the third uh quality of
plasma dna extraction kits that we have
is the advanced
transfection and this is for your
gene therapy and for vaccine development
so it's the purest of
plasmid prep kits that you can get to
make sure that you have really clean dna
before you're using it in a
gene therapy or vaccine setting
so one tip that we um that's fairly new
that we offer for the molecular grade so
this would be for
your initial starting point when you're
looking at plasmas for vaccine
development you want to make sure that
you have the right
maybe gene um section in your plasmid
you would use this molecular version for
a quick screening
is the pure link fast flow endotoxin
plasmid kit
the benefit of this kit is that it has
colored buffers so it makes it really
easy to know which buffer you're
grabbing you don't have to
you know be so meticulous in reading the
label you can just look for the blue
buffer or the pink buffer
which makes it a little bit easier to
work with but it's very quick it only
takes about 30 minutes to completely
do a maxi prep for isolating
up to 1.5 milligrams of plasma dna
and it's also actually quite clean as
well you get low endotoxin it's not
endotoxin-free but it's still quite
clean for
such a quick plasmid prep
this is some example data from using the
purelink fast flow endotoxin kit
as compared to a couple of other kits
the purelink fast is in the dark
red so this is the total yield that we
received from a maxi kit
as compared to a competitor kit and then
one of our other
internal kits that purely high pure so
the fast kit actually provides
equivalent quality plasma dna as shown
in the gel picture
but it's um you get more
more yield out of it which is the
benefit of using
this particular kit
the next level of that i wanted to talk
about for plasma dna is the advanced
transfections plasma dna and so this is
using our purelink xp
endotoxin-free plasmid kits so these
isolate again
up to 1.5 milligrams of high quality
plasma dna from a maxi prep kit
but here these are endotoxin free and we
just we
determined endotoxin-free as if it has
less than 0.1
endotoxin units per microgram of dna um
and so it's beneficial for use in
plants uh excuse me and transfections
and for vaccine development for gene
therapy
um some of the um you know
uh more challenging uh plasmid uses
um this was where you would want to use
this kit because it's very clean
very high quality dna to be able to use
in those downstream applications
and then again this is some example data
from the
fat kit using either the maxi the mega
or the giga we have all three scales
available
so initially you may want to start out
with just the maxi kit
so that you can do a look-see the how
well it's working
and then whenever you realize that this
is the plasma that we want to move
forward with for
you know maybe your vaccine development
you would scale up and go to the mega
and giga scale so that you can get more
of that plasma to be able to work with
and here in these graphs we are
comparing it to one of our competitor
kits
that actually uses gravity column the
benefit of the purelink xp kit is that
it uses
vacuum manifolds to clarify
and bind and elute the
plasma dna so it's much quicker workflow
than the gravity flow columns that you
might get from other companies
um and then as you can see here the red
bars
show the purelink xp kit yields compared
to the gravity columns in the blue so
you get quite a bit more
for all three scales if you use the
purelink xp kit
and this again is using the pureling xb
kit and
the um and showing compatibility with
the transient expression system and matt
will talk a little bit more about this
later on
about what the expression system is but
it's a
it's a kit that's entirely comprised of
everything that you would need to be
able to do expression from a plasmid
into getting that protein expression
and so here you can see that compared to
competitor kits we get equivalent or
better results
for the expression of the xb293 or the
expedro system
and then this is another experiment
showing the performance of the plasma
that you would get from the purelink xv
the endotoxin-free kit here what we did
was i
ran a gel just to show that you get
equivalent
banding patterns with the pure link kits
which are the lanes marked one two and
three as compared to
a competitor kit that's labeled q1 and
q2
so even though the xp kit uses the
vacuum manifold to speed up the process
you get equivalent quality
as compared to the gravity flow through
columns
and it happens in a much quicker
turnaround time
the second graph shows the yield that
you would get as well as the time
change time savings that you get so the
pure link you get um
a little bit more than four and a half
uh milligrams of yield
whereas with the competitor it's um
about three and it takes half the time
as it does with the competitor because
as i mentioned it uses the vacuum
manifold compared to the gravity flow
and then those same plasmids were done
into a transfection
of hela cells just to show how well they
would transfect and
you get equivalent expression of this
was using um luciferase so you could
express
equivalent expression of the luciferase
um
with um all the replicates that you get
from the purelink kit as
which are labeled the pl one two and
three those are the pure link kits as
compared to the competitor q1 and q2
and then the negative control there just
shows that there's um
no background and so those are the um
the highlights of some of our portfolio
for sample prep products
that could be helpful in the vaccine
research and vaccine development
and if you have any questions feel free
to add them into the chat
and with that i will pass it over to our
next speaker who is kettle
so thank you very much
well thanks a lot and that brings us
over to
the intact virus and how to isolate
the interactors so now we have been
addressing the nucleic acids
so so the genome of the virus and now i
will
talk a little bit about how to
enrich and isolate the intact virus
by the use of our newly launched
products
so these junior products they actually
have the capability to
genera generically capture uh the virus
for which they can then be used for
further uh characterization
uh of the virus itself but also to study
viral host interactions or even
also development of testing drugs
and vaccines at different biosafety
levels
so typically the starting material for a
viral
sample preparation is either viral
transport media
or also from cell culture media
where you have grown your cells infected
cells releasing
virus particles into the media but also
from a waste water so the two new
products that we have just launched
one is based upon magnetic beads they
are the dynabits
and the one is that the other one is
based upon precipitation
so in this way it's possible to
quickly enrich the virus in a generic
way
so we're not targeting any surface
markers of the virus
at all and also since
the one of those products are magnetic
beads they can of course be
the whole workflow can then be automated
so you can
automate the virus isolation using the
kingfisher
platform and those captured
by intact viruses are then suitable for
a different
a range of different downstream
applications
such as further virus culture to produce
more virus
for distribution or for functional
studies
basic research work around vaccine
development
but also for wastewater
surveillance and not to forget
proteomics
and and genomics
so in terms of viral
enrichment so what kind of methods are
are commonly used uh to to isolate these
hundred nanometer sized
vesicles so we are not talking about
structures that
are in the range of of also on exosomes
there are several methods or principles
used
are that are commonly used for
enrichment
and isolation and those are based upon
charge
some of them are using filtration there
are also different forms of
ultra-centrifugation
and gradient sucrose gradients
centrifugation that are
typically used and not to forget
the the precipitation but all these
methods
they do face different challenges
and i've just mentioned a comparison
here
in terms of yield so how much virus can
you get out
using these common um
enrichment methods and typically here we
see that
for instance ultra centrifugation can
cause
a huge loss of samples during
the the sample preparation
so when we developed the our new two new
products for
for capturing the source code to a virus
we did use both wires like particles
which are particles that does not
contain any nucleic acids at
all so then you can work on this in a
bsl1
facility and we also used inactivated or
heat inactivated source cover to
bars as a model system
as we can use this inactivate virus also
in our facility
but of course we have also tested these
two products
at the bsl3 facility
isolating intact and infectious
uh virus just to make sure to
demonstrate that
that these two products can can
isolate the infectious virus as well
and also to demonstrate that after
isolation the virus
are still infectious
so so these two products will then
capture the virus that
is in the viral transport media or
in the wastewater or it will also
isolate the viruses that have been
released
into the cell culture media from the
infected
infected cells so allowing for a very
rapid
capture of these viruses that are
suitable for
for any downstream application and i can
also then
as i will show you some data in the end
they
are can then be used upstream
the magmax magmax kit
so how does these two new products
actually work
okay let's let's have a look at the
dynabits first so these are
magnetic bits that you can use for
automation so you can use an automated
platform a bead mover
that will do the whole protocol for you
these beads here are strong anion
exchange speeds so they are positively
charged
beads that are surrounded with a
protective layer of
chloride ions and those negatively
charged
ions then will then be replaced by the
negatively charged
virus and this binding kinetics is
super fast so we actually have a
protocol that allows for capture within
minutes
i think the total or the overall
protocol time
is around 20 minutes it can
possibly be a lot shorter than that as
well
and also interestingly if you add a
counter ion negatively charged cantor
ion that has stronger affinity
than the virus then you can also
release the virus from the beads after
after capture and the virus will still
be
infectious so this allows for
numerous uh downstream applications
wastewater testing but also functional
assays
and not forget the nucleic acid
applications
the other product is based upon
precipitation so you're actually
removing
water from the surroundings and then
collapsing
the the viruses uh into the bottom
of the tube so this is also a very
efficient
uh pre-enriched uh enrichment
of of these virus which are
and those viruses are unsuitable for
also for this
for the same downstream application
obviously since there's no magnetic
beads involved in this product
automation is not an option for
for these for this method
okay so so then i will share with you
some data that we have
obtained during product
development
so in these data sets here
we have spiked in virus-like particles
into cell culture media and viral
transport media and then we have
captured
the virus by using these dynabits the
strong anion exchange speeds
and we have used both a manual a manual
protocol but also
the protocol that we have optimized and
fine-tuned
on the kingfisher instrument and
actually we have tested it on all
the different instruments that we offer
the apex which
are which is the brand new
uh instrument that have been launched
just uh
some months ago and then we have the
flex instrument
but also the tiny little duo prime
instrument which
i really appreciate because it helps us
also
in in our product development a very
a nice little instrument but here we
have demonstrated the isolation
efficiency
so now we're talking about a protocol
that are 20 minutes
all in all capturing the virus
and we can see the capture efficiency
here
on the western blots where we have
identified the nuclear capsid protein as
a as a marker for
for the virus so the capture efficiency
is
equally as good in in world transport
media but also
in cell culture cell culture media
and the data does not demonstrate the
manual versus
automated but i can assure you that that
these are exactly the same
and not to forget of course the
downstream qpcr so we have repeated
those experiments
testing uh several different
batches of these strong alien exchange
speeds
capture the various from viral transport
media or cell culture media
and then processed them using
using the mfb2 kit downstream
the bead-based isolation and then
identified the structural genes the
n-gene s-gene but also the
non-structural
or 1ab gene by
qpcr very very efficient
uh and also the second product uh this
is the
non-bead-based product so it's the
precipitation product
uh works equally well uh as
as the dynabids the the magnetic
bead-based
uh isolation so just by precipitating
out the virus and then
followed by by the mvp toolkit and the
um qpcr
identifying at the end gene and the s
gene and the non-structural of one a b
g so anyway i've tested also different
batches
of of these precipitation regions
showing very good performance
and then this is also um at the protein
level
um where we have tested a range of
of different lots here where we have
precipitated out
the virus and undetected the
nucleocapsid
protein from from viral transport media
but also for
for cell culture media so in this
particular experiments we have used the
viral transport media
for this so so to sum up we have two
very nice
products that can capture
intact virus it can capture intact
infectious virus these are the data that
have not shown here
which have been processed in the bsl3
lab where we have
captured the virus with these two
products and then
um seeded those wires out
in a plaque assay and then counted
plaques as a measure
of number of infectious particles
and that really bypassed the uh the
the centrifugation approach uh by
a large so
the isolation efficiency was a lot
higher for the for the
base precipitation based versus the
ultracentrifugation based
method so all in all we i think we can
say that we have
two pretty ver pretty good products for
isolation of intact uh viral particles
and with this i would like to hand it
over to matt
thanks kettle
thank you for the opportunity to talk
about harnessing the the power of
our xp expression systems in vaccine
development
lost the ability to advance slides
so we always start off with the the
central dogma what is protein expression
protein expression is the method of
producing proteins using our cell lines
we're
using our cells as factories in order to
produce some proteins
you know in this case we're starting
with plasma dna
um going through transcription into a
messenger rna translation
into uh the expression of our our
protein in this case
the end protein that specifically is the
the spike protein on sarsko v2
are these slides advancing for people
as sasha mentioned before there are two
sorry i'm getting
how's that look thank you
sorry um so there are two methods for
expressing proteins and you can do so in
a transit fashion or a stable fashion
and the method that you choose has a lot
of factors that go into that decision
the amount of protein that you need the
speed to protein
is also very important and how many
proteins you need to express
um in the shortest amount of time with a
transient expression
you can scramble through
numerous hundreds and thousands of
proteins in a very short amount of time
you know within
four to twelve days you can go from a
glycerol stock or
purified plasmid dna to your purified
protein
so that ability to to get your protein
as
as quickly as possible is a major factor
in determining what
methods that you use traditionally once
you've identified
a certain protein you want to scale up
and increase the the uniformity of that
that protein
it's it's profile it's it's um
effectiveness of um of your
therapeutic um for this instance
um but this is going to take months if
not um
if not years in some cases to develop
that that stable expression
cell line um to obtain you know large
amounts of protein
for scale up
so when specifically thinking about the
needs of a vaccine researcher
the ability to get to the highest amount
of protein in the shortest amount of
time is a major determining factor
it needs to be scalable your process
needs to be cost effective
and it needs to be efficient um to get
to those large scale
production capabilities if um things
look good on the research
and development end of your workflow
they need to um
look good at the the tail end of your
workflow when you're going into
manufacturing and commercialization
otherwise
you're without a product
here at thermo fisher we have our gibco
solutions for protein
expression the xb cell lines for
for protein expression when focusing on
mammalian protein expression we have the
xb293 and the xb
cho systems they're great for
obtaining a large amount of protein in a
short amount of time
specifically when focused on the xb293
system
they can uh express a wide range of
proteins and protein formats in a short
amount of time
the expedro system is fantastic for
excreting
or expressing secreted proteins
antibodies fc fusions
fouls by specifics and multi-specifics
when focusing on
an insect-based cell line our xbsf
system is a
sf9 based cell line that has a one
cell line for the generation of your
bacco virus
straight through the production of your
protein and a
fully chemically fined animal or animal
origin free and
beastoid free media
with the xp systems we take a kit based
approach so this eliminates the
the guesswork of pairing different cell
lines with different medias with
different feeds with different
enhancers and different dna vectors we
take that
years of research and development out of
your hands um
and present you with the xp solutions
the
xb23 xp cho and xbsf for your protein
production needs
and when specifically looking at the
vaccine development workflow
these xp systems can support
your research from the r d in
pre-clinical stages straight through
clinical and manufacturing stages we
have both
ruo versions of the cells and also and
gmp-banked cell lines for
that ultimate commercialization and
clinical manufacturing of your product
and with the ability of the xp cho
system you can now
get and show and stay and show as we
like to say some
so the proteins that you express in a
transient fashion
will be uh will have the same qualities
of uh
your proteins expressed in a stable
fashion in that xp chill system so you
can get a nice early book
in a quick quick early look of your
protein in a transient setting and then
progress into a stable
cell line knowing that those
characteristics aren't going to change
in addition to the vaccine development
support that rxb systems have been able
to provide we've also supported
the diagnostic use in
serological assays so specifically
the rdt test or the rapid diagnostic
test
which is that lateral flow elisa that
quick and sometimes dirty lateral flow
elisa that can
quickly sometimes accurately sometimes
not accurately determine if
a patient is testing positive for
start for a coveted 19 stars cov2 um
with a look at um testing for
the patient's antibodies in that lateral
flow assay
um the neutralization assay is another
asset that we've
been able to support with our different
cell lines um this test relies on
the patient antibodies to detect
the level of efficacy in a lab setting
of those
antibodies against uh either a pseudo
virus or live
sarco v2 it's able to um
also be a a quantitative um a
quantitative assay and so it can tell
you the effectiveness and
the different dosing strategies or
titration strategies of your
of your antibodies and ultimately um
and finally the we like to focus on the
enzyme-linked
immunoabsorbent assay or the elisa
this test can also be qualitative or
quantitative
and it relies on a plate-based format to
screen
antibodies against the spike protein and
the rbd
in the context of cova 19 these tests
are
most frequently used to test the
patient's igg
and iv igm antibodies
the presence of igg and ign antibodies
here we'd like to focus on the kramer
serological
as our protocol florian cramer is a
researcher at the
icon school of medicine at mount sinai
and early on in the pandemic he released
a
a protocol detailing his use of xb293
system to produce the rbd and spike
proteins
to support this serological
assay or eliza that he developed this is
a two-part screen
initially the patient samples are
screened against
the rbd the receptor binding domain
portion of the the following spike
and then um confirmed uh base uh
confirmed with a binding to the the
spike
uh full length spike protein um once
again a
a plate-based format so 96-0 or 384
wealth
fashion so it's a pretty rapid screen
and very
accurate so it can also
be used to diagnose asymptomatic uh
patients
that are positive for for psoriasis v2
this has been a very popular protocol
and
he's shared it very widely around the
world
so it's been very fortunate to be able
to support the the use of
xb293 in this pursuit and development of
the stereological alasa
protocol
here at uh thermofisher we like to say
we are one thermofisher
for your vaccine development solutions
as the previous presenters have uh
mentioned we have
a ton of different products that can
support every aspect of
your workflow and your your development
of vaccines
from the early stages in r d support
straight through your clinical
manufacturing and clinical services
with that we can open up to questions
all right well
thank you sasha laura kettle
and matt for your informative
presentation
we will now start the version of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located in the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started uh
speakers do you want to come back on
camera
here we go okay i will start out here
our first question is what is the
advantage
of mrna vaccines over other vaccine
types
if you may want to unmute yourself if
you're talking
there's so many buttons i know it says
the
there we go i think i can hear you
no
sasha we can't hear you there you go oh
this is not
oh that's matt okay i think you know
what leaps out and jumps to mind is the
the speed um
of that development of that vaccine um
and it's going to be
much quicker than the development of say
a subunit vaccine or a live
attenuated vaccine so as sasha mentioned
before that that
that shift that paradigm shift from um
the subunits or the lives attenuated
vaccines to
the messenger rna vaccine development
was you know
it took months or weeks instead of
decades
all right it was really fast thank you
matt anybody else want to add to that
i'll move on to the next question
does does in rna distraction
the lysis method affect the ran value
also in order to increase concentration
of rna
what all conditions should be maintained
i'll take that one um
so yes the the license method does
affect the rin value
um so the rin is your integrity number
for those that may not be familiar it's
your rna integrity number
and so how you lyse your sample
definitely affects that
so you want to fat you want to life it
fairly quickly in a lysis buffer that's
going to stabilize your rna
and also inactivate rnases so most of
your commercially available kits are
going to have a license buffer that will
do that
you could use trisol you could use like
the pure link kits the magma
kits that i mentioned earlier all of
those will have a license buffer that
will do that
um some things that you might want to
keep in mind is if the sample like if
it's a piece of tissue that's frozen
you generally don't want to thaw that
before lysing it because that will allow
the rnases to activate and then degrade
your rna so you'll want to
drop the piece of tissue into the lysis
buffer and homogenize it
while it's still frozen we typically use
a polytron which is kind of like an
immersion blender
to do that for frozen pieces of tissue
because that's going to
be the easiest way to do that a mortar
and pestle will also work if you have
that available
and the other part of that question for
how can you increase your concentration
of rna
the biggest thing is just scale so um
you want to lice in an appropriate
volume
the kits generally will provide a lysis
volume for your sample size volume so
you'll want to follow that protocol
and follow those recommendations for how
much license buffer to use
per your sample size and then also you
can try to
decrease your aleutian buffer
depending on what kit you're using there
are also some kits that are
for small like if it's a really small
sample
size a really small piece of tissue or
small number of cells
you can use the kit that's specifically
designed for that so that it will
maximize your concentration
so those were the those are the um the
things that i would suggest
all right thank you looks like we lost a
few but they may be logging back in so
they can
connect their audio so i will go ahead
and ask another question and if we need
to move on if someone else needs to
answer this we can do that
so the question is what type what kind
of vaccine
is the is easier than the other types to
prepare
i think that kind of goes back to what
matt mentioned earlier is the mrna
vaccines are generally a little bit
easier
faster at least to make for some of the
attenuated viruses you know you have to
have the whole virus and activate it
somehow before you can go into the
vaccine so um i think the mrnas
are going to be easier i think they
might move to be the primary type of
vaccine in the future
but that's and we'll just have to see
how it goes and
what people are comfortable with
thank you uh okay we'll go ahead and
we'll just keep asking questions and
hopefully they'll pop back in
can the xb293 and the xbcho i may be
saying that wrong and i apologize if i
am
cell lines be used to produce stable
cell lines expressing a protein of
interest
i can take that one all right yes it's
going to be based on
your vector of choice and the selection
marker that you
uh include in that vector and then you
can stably select those those cell lines
especially in your protein based on that
antibody resistance that's
included in that vector or the for the
stable integration of the genome with
the cells
all right thank you matt we have another
question
are you aware of any publications that
optimize the kramer serological assay
and or
any that compare and contrast rbd and
spike protein expression
in xb293 and xbcho
yes we have a fantastic publication hub
of highlighting the use of xp systems
for
for vaccine development um including a
nice paper
from dom esposito at the frederick
national cancer lab
where he optimized foreign creamers
protocol to increase
spike level and rbd level of protein
expression um
and yes also in that publication hub um
there's another paper
um out of albert einstein
um highlighting the the use of xp cho
and xb293 for the production of
rbd and spike proteins
can i pop that in the chat sure
thank you matt okay
can you hear us or if not i can hear you
now yes
that's fantastic i'm not sure what
happens so i can briefly add to some of
the early questions about advantages of
mrna so first of all it doesn't
affect our dna in any way it's very safe
approach to use
then mrna is easier than dna to deliver
inside cells upon in vivo injections so
the goal is to deliver the target of the
cytoplasm
and it's much easier accomplishment
versus trying to deliver something into
nucleus
and the finalists with mrna so the
beauty of it is that the antigen
is amplifies when you introduce even one
molecule of mrna inside cells
uh many molecules of protein can be
produced from it in course of process
called uh the transcription or the
translation then
so compared to protein where you need to
deliver several molecules of antigens
which is like more complicated
so the mrna allows you to amplify their
signal and
produce more antigens inside the living
body
and which vaccine is easier to
uh just prepare than others it's a tough
question so
inactivate it and life at native
vaccines they're easy to prepare and
that's why they we use historically in
the early days of exchange development
but they are so the process is not so
well controlled and it's kind of tricky
and it's an old-school
method so if you're in the harris so
definitely it's something worth
considering
modern day vaccines many of them are
sub-unit and recombinant which take time
and it's an art so it's not a great
success so these are more complicated
ones
and the main excitement right now is all
about mrna as martin laura says so this
seems to be the
really revolutionary technology going
way further than just vaccine
applications into mrna therapeutic area
there are currently several uh companies
including modern driving this
development to the amazing are making
amazing progress right now since
the first success story was covet
vaccine but now there are several
other vaccines and the therapeutic in
this in their pipeline already in the
later stages
so that the world as we know it
hopefully will change in the next one or
two years and it will be a totally new
era for vaccine development which is
really exciting
thank you sasha i'm so glad we have you
back
okay i'm gonna i really only have time
for about one more question here
so um can the microbiome kit be used for
wastewater samples
i'll answer that one um yes we actually
um
have gotten a lot of inquiries about
this because a lot of people are using
wastewater as
a uh kind of a surveillance tool for
looking to see if there are hot spots
for
sars coast ii um virus within the
community
and so there's um an application note
that one of our colleagues wrote and put
together
and kettle mentioned it as well um
so there's an application on the
thermostat website that talks about how
you can use it
but you can use the microbiome kit with
waste water samples and
if you're using a small volume like one
milliliter you can use it directly
using the microbiome kit with the one
milliliter of wastewater as your sample
type
and if you're using a larger volume the
ask note has a protocol for how to
concentrate that so that you can use
up to i believe it's up to 50
milliliters of wastewater
all right thank you laura and thank you
again to all of you all of our speakers
uh sasha vlasso laura chapman kettle
peterson
and matt mckenna for your time today and
for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsors thermo fisher
scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
thank you thank you thank you bye